In another lesson later on we're going to be looking at architectural views.
But to anticipate that I'll just mention that
architectural description is not just a diagram, it's a set of decisions. And
in fact the, in order to fully communicate that set of decisions,
many diagrams and/or textual documents might be produced. We call
these architectural views. Because the set of decisions may be large, and
there may be many different aspects to it, okay? Over the course of time various
different kinds of diagrams and tables have been developed and found useful and
so we want to be aware of what those are so if you are confronted by a situation
where you need to convey some aspects of the architecture, you have you're aware
of the various diagrams and, and textural processes you could apply.